hi there my name is ed cutrell and i'm
really happy to welcome you to our
webinar today
designing computer vision algorithms to
describe the visual world of people who
are blind or low vision
i'm joined here today with donna
guerrari the assistant professor of
school of information at the university
of texas in austin
she is an expert in computer vision
machine learning crowdsourcing
accessibility
and biomedical image analysis
my name is ed cudrle again i'm a senior
principal researcher here at microsoft
in the ability group and my focus is on
computing for disability and
accessibility and inclusive design
and in particular i have a long career
in human computer interaction
i want to remind you that if you're here
for the initial broadcast
you can actually ask us some questions
on the little webinar widget
so just make sure you do that for us
let's start out talking a little bit
about accessibility now
accessibility generally is a notion of
how we provide
options for people with different
abilities to then be able to get
done what they want to do and this can
apply to a range of different kinds
of disabilities from vision hearing
cognitive disabilities mobility speaking
there's a big wide range of things that
this might actually incorporate
but to understand this a little bit
better we need to think about disability
now there's been a huge change in how we
define disability in just in the past
40 or 50 years now if you go back to
and you listen to the world health
organization and their definition of
disability
they define it as any restriction or
lack of ability resulting from an
impairment
to perform an activity in the manner or
within the range considered normal
for a human being okay so that's really
framing it around
a lack of ability there now if you think
about the way it is now
they refer to it as disability is not
just a health problem
it's a complex phenomenon reflecting the
interaction between features of a
person's body
and features of the society in which he
or she lives
so if we think about that a little bit
better or in a slightly higher view
this ability is just a mismatch between
the abilities of a person
and what they're really trying to do the
capability or the situation
that they're in so i want to make very
clear that when we think about
disability in this context it's not
a personal health condition it's really
a mismatch between
what the person is able to do and the
human interaction that they're expected
to be doing to try to get what they're
trying to get done let's think about
this
in an example so we can often think
about this on a spectrum going from sort
of
long-term of a disability to a very
short-term thing now the very longest
term
you've got a congenital disability maybe
you were born without use of your legs
in which case your mobility is impaired
in a particular way
for your entire life there's an acquired
disability
where as you age you become have more
and more
trouble um walking for instance so you
need to use a walker
an assistance there's a temporary
disability
so you break a leg and you need to use a
roller
to get around and then there's a
situational impairment
i need to move my kids around in a
stroller at that point
right now for all of these kinds of
disabilities
you can have similar kinds of solutions
or ways of
meeting those things and the classic
example of this is a curb cut
curb cuts are initially designed for
people in wheelchairs
but then they actually are useful for a
huge range of people
along the spectrum of disability
now this is true for all different kinds
of disabilities not just
a movement it applies to seeing you can
imagine
people that are blind people that have
cataracts but then the cataracts can be
removed and repaired
or maybe just a distracted driver many
of the same situations apply to all
three
same thing for hearing you have the case
of a person who's deaf
you've got an ear infection so i can't
hear until that ear infection is cleared
up
or there's a case of a bartender in a
really noisy space where they can't hear
anything
while they're in that space and then
similarly you know in the case of
speaking
all the way from non-verbal all the way
up to just a very heavy accent
now when we think about how to design
for people with disabilities
um we really need to sort of think about
this from this entire spectrum that i
just talked about
and the interesting thing is that by
designing
for people with the impairment we
automatically
wind up building in benefits for a huge
range of people
another example of that i showed you the
curb cuts earlier but another great
example of this
is subtitling and captioning now this is
a technology that was really built
for people that are deaf and hard of
hearing but it turns out
that this is extremely useful for people
in for instance in an airport
or now more recently with mobile phones
facebook now includes captioning in
almost
all of their videos because people don't
want to be bothering everyone around
them
they want to be able to still enjoy
their cat videos
and then another example is teaching a
child to read where there's been a lot
of research showing
that captioning that goes along with the
sound can help children
learn to read so there's a case here of
a technology
that was built for people with a very
specific long-term impairment
that now applies to all kinds of people
but now let's get this back into maybe
microsoft land
i work at microsoft and this is
important near and dear to my heart
um one of the things that's happened
recently is we've actually
now released as part of powerpoint
the ability to automatically add alt
text captioning
to an image that you insert into
um powerpoint so in this case this is a
photograph of my darling kitten tarly
and he the caption that's automatically
generated by computer vision algorithm
is a cat
lying on the ground that's actually a
pretty good
caption and this is a really nice
benefit
of using computer vision technology to
sort of start to benefit people
that are visually impaired so alt text
if just
to be clear about this for people who
don't know it this is the way that
people who use
screen readers and this is where they
read out
information on a screen can get
information now obviously there are
problems when they run across an image
how do they find out alt text is how you
find out about
what that image is actually saying and
you can imagine that if you don't have
alt text
that you've got an entire class of
information that just
goes away for people that are visually
impaired
now while this works really well in many
instances
it also can start to fall over in other
cases
now this is an example of an image that
appeared in twitter a few years ago when
hillary clinton was running for
president
so this was four years ago and she
writes this tweet that says
some on the other side may say the best
days are behind us let's prove them
wrong and she's ascending
the stage with a big smile on her face
and it's great right
now we ran this through an automatic
captioning system
and the response was i'm not really
confident that i think it's a man doing
a trick on a skateboard at night
now in some level you say that's just
ridiculous and of course
why would hillary clinton be using an
image of a person on a skateboard that
just doesn't make any sense
but in fact when we talked with blind
users who
use twitter regularly about this image
and about this caption
this is what they had to say there was
actually no question they just assumed
the caption was correct and they said
well you know if you say there's an
older man on a skateboard at night that
makes sense and that's the way i take
our best days are behind us because i'm
an old lady so i like that idea
so what you can see is that even though
this captioning
had some problems with it that are kind
of obvious to people that are sighted
and can see it
if you're blind you may actually start
to believe that
and just try to make up a story about
why that's true so this just starts to
point at
how important this area is and how
getting these captions right
are really really important for people
that can't see
so i just want to sort of close up this
little section on accessibility by
talking
by mentioning that computer vision
offers us
an incredible set of capabilities and
they have the
potential to improve the lives of
millions and millions of people
now the problem that we have to be
careful about is that the tools
have to be matched to what the people
want and need
and allows them to build in their own
capabilities and not just what we're
trying to do
for them so with that what i want to do
is to bring up donna who's going to talk
about the specific
issue here that we're going to talk
about around using computer vision
and captioning so driven by the desire
to support real users
we decided to embark on helping real
users who rely
on on-demand visual assistance so at
present
people who are blind can take their
mobile phone take a picture
optionally record a spoken question
and have that sent off to remote humans
who in turn will either return a caption
or an answer if a question was provided
an example looks like this given an
image a caption might say
a bunch of small light brown mushrooms
in a green field
or given a question is it edible or
poisonous
you might answer poisonous
this kind of technology has existed now
for about a decade
and we've observed an increasing number
of technologies that are emerging to
support this kind of scenario
the goal of our work is how do we teach
computers to automatically describe
these pictures
taken by people who are blind
so let's take a view of what is the
typical pipeline for training computer
vision algorithms
to see it takes three steps
first build a large scale data set
second
design an algorithm train it evaluate it
and finally
take that algorithm and deploy it for
real users
and if we zoom into those first two
steps with an example
this is analogous to how you might teach
a child
so if you want to show a child an image
and ask is there a person
in the image you might do this
by showing the child many examples where
there are people
in different sizes shapes configurations
and more
so this is what we do today with
algorithms we train algorithms by
showing them
as many examples as possible
there are several problems with this
pipeline today
one is that there's often a mismatch
between real users needs
and what is used in the data sets
two is that we consequently will have a
mismatch between the algorithms
and their ability to handle the data
sets
and then the third is that it turns out
that the kinds of problems we're
thinking about
aren't necessarily covered by today's
computer vision methods
so thinking about what are the new
problems we need to address
so i'm going to go through these three
examples for the remainder of the talk
so diving into the first one
what i show here are three examples on
the top from the existing data set used
by the community
three examples on the bottom from real
users
and prior work has predominantly been
collecting the pictures and the
questions independently
pictures are collected from the internet
questions are contrived
often generated by a person who has
shown the image and asked to ask a
question
so you'll see a bias where many of the
questions know what is an image
such as is the bus moving
in contrast real users are a scenario
where it's the same person who took the
picture
and asked the question and data reflects
real users interests
such as learning the flavor of food the
temperature on thermostat
as well as whether or not their sneakers
match
so the first effort that we took in
solving this
challenge is we decided to make a data
set
we worked off of an existing repository
of data where over 11 000 people
submitted over 72 000 requests between
2011 and 2015
and we used 62 percent of the requests
for which users agreed to share their
data
this data came from real users so it was
very important to make sure that we kept
their identities private
so we took steps such as anonymizing the
data
by transcribing the questions to remove
their voices
as well as resaving the images to remove
any metadata such as their location
we next came up with a way to remove all
personally identifiable information
so we came up with a taxonomy of what is
private information
and then went through all the images to
remove any that contain that information
and text the taxonomy includes people's
faces
their prescription pills as well as
their mail that might show their address
or their personal information
and then we took those remaining images
we went to
online crowd workers with amazon
mechanical turk and we quit we collected
captions and answers
the results is two new data sets a
visual question answering data set for
which we have 10 answers for every
official question
as well as an image captioning data set
for which we have five captions
for every image
this data set is very challenging for
the community for a number of reasons
including that many of the images are
low quality
many contain text and many contain novel
concepts such as showing currency or
showing captchas and it turns out many
of these participants are also taking a
lot of pictures of kellogg branded food
insofar as exploring this data set we
encourage you to hop on to our website
and check it out you can look at the
images
you know a sample of the images that
we're taking as is being shown on the
screen
you can also click on any image to see
what question was asked what do the town
crowdsource answers look like
as well as what do the captions look
like on the your left side you can also
see that there's a search bar that
allows you to search for specific
concepts
in the questions as well as the answers
and the captions as well as more
metadata
given that we produced a data set we
next wanted to explore
the design of algorithms that match the
data set challenges so to do this
i'm just going to kind of outline what
is the typical approach for evaluating
algorithms
so we have a data set in this case we
have a bunch of images with questions
and then answers so i show this in
abstract form
and the way we typically evaluate is we
would take that data set
split it into a training set and a test
set
then train the algorithm on the training
set to try to minimize some prediction
error on it
and then take that train model and apply
the algorithm on the test set to
minimize to
measure the generalization error so for
example if we have these two examples we
would take that algorithm
apply it to the first one we'd see it's
a matching predicted
caption or answer do it for the second
one see it's incorrect
we'd do that for all the examples tally
all the results and then come up with
a score saying how well the methods did
so we did this for three different
scenarios
in the first scenario we looked at what
happens when we train today's state of
art algorithms
using today's state of art computer
vision data sets
and we evaluated with respect to a
number of different measures
without going into the details here's
the results in a nutshell
they don't do well so then we said
well maybe the algorithms are right
maybe it's just that they weren't
trained on the right data
so we next tested what happens when we
take those algorithms
and we train it on the data from people
who are blind
so we did that this shows
that there is a slight improvement
overall we see a rise in scores but
nonetheless we see
the algorithms are still not doing well
across the many metrics
so we did a final test which said we're
going to train the data we're going to
train those algorithms on both
the old data sets and the new data sets
and see how it does
yet again we're not getting good results
so in a nutshell today's algorithms are
not sufficient
um here's an example of a mistake given
this image
this is the outcome from an algorithm
which believes that it's a man
who is holding his head on a cell phone
clearly not correct
and so just to reiterate what what's
challenging about this data set for
algorithms
it's that many images are low quality
contain text and have novel concepts
so to make progress on this important
problem
we've actually shared all of our data
sets publicly to engage a larger
community
to accelerate progress so you can find
the data sets again at our website
we also have our data set being shared
in other locations such as academic
torrents kaggle and facebook's platform
and in addition we're providing a public
evaluation server with leaderboards
to monitor how different teams are doing
so you can see a current
list of all the participants with the
ranking of how they stand on the
international stage
we invite everyone to come and join in
we are ignoring organizing events to
foster community and celebrate progress
we had the last event in 2018 and we do
have our next event in 2020 and so we
invite others to come and join on this
challenge
and make progress and the
progress is being celebrated by many who
are writing articles
about this data set as well as their
success
on making progress on this data set
so now let's dive into the third
key challenge which is revealing users
new problems
so again we have this pipeline where
people are submitting their
images with optionally questions and
wanting to get captions or answers
but if we take a look at the user's data
we see that several issues are
emerging the first is that
nine percent of over the 39 000 images
we analyzed
have quality issues that are too severe
to recognize the content
meaning forget trying to get some sort
of caption to describe that image we
probably should notify the user
hey try to take another image
we also found that 29 of the
31 000 visual questions we analyzed are
not answerable
so for example with the question what is
the expiration date
the picture does not capture that
information within the image
and this is true for the other examples
such as what is this a gift card for
what temperature is the dial set to
and then the next challenge is that 12
of all the images that we analyzed show
private content private content can
include showing people's faces
credit card numbers pregnancy test
results
information on computer screens as well
as information about their prescription
pills
and of these privacy disclosures one out
of every 40 were intentional
because people needed to learn about
their private content they took the
trade-off of sharing their private
information
in order to get that information
so we also are introducing a number of
new problems with dataset challenges to
address
these new problems we should be thinking
about as a community
one is given an image decide whether or
not that content can be recognized
another is given a question about an
image
decide whether it can be answered
and then the next one is given an image
decide whether it contains private
content
and as before all these data sets are
going to be publicly shared
at our website
and so that summarizes
the work we are working on to teach
computers to automatically describe
pictures taken by people who are blind
as i noted there are some key problems
with the data set the algorithms and
really understanding the real users
needs
that hopefully we've inspired you to
want to move forward with
so to summarize we offer a new data set
challenges which empower the ai
community to work on real use cases
our algorithm analysis reveals open
technical challenges for the ai
community
and our data set analysis reveals new
important ai problems for supporting
real
users there are many people who have
been involved in the work that we are
presenting today
some include our mentees with little
images shown
in the right our colleagues there are
many who have supported the development
of these data set challenges
and there's also thousands of crowd
workers who have dedicated tens of
thousands of hours
towards helping make this possible
and so i want to close with inviting you
to join our challenges to design more
generalized algorithms that address
real users needs as i mentioned we are
having a workshop in 2020
it will be in seattle and we'll be
announcing the winners of our day set
challenges
and at this time i'd love to invite you
to join us for our live q
a
all right hi everyone this is ed cutrell
i want to thank you all for attending
our webinar
and live q a on designing computer
vision algorithms for describing
the visual world to people who are blind
or low vision
um i'm joined here today with donna
guerrari
and over the next 15 minutes or so we'll
be answering questions that are
submitted
by the audience all of you folks so
let's get started um our first question
today is about
let me get get my list of questions here
there was a question early on that
was talked about about are there places
where
technology is developed for some
disability might actually cause
problems for other people this is a
really good question and it's it's a
deep question about the ethics of the
way we build these ai models
donna would you like to address this
absolutely
um so a number of examples come to mind
people want image captioning whether
they are traversing
a if they're looking at a newspaper
or if they're on a dating website or if
they're on a shopping website
and an example where the technology
might present concerns
you might think about on a dating
website where someone's going on
they would like some sort of guidance of
what they're seeing
on the people and a technology might
provide some sort of details about the
person's characteristics
this could include things like their you
know the presumed race
a presumed gender opportune body
shape um a presumed attractiveness and
more
and that's highly controversial uh some
people
would claim they would want those
details while others would claim
that's you know that's unethical to
provide
and so there are certainly a lot of
discussions
and decisions that have to be made about
how much
do you portray about the visual world
and whether it's ethical to not share
such
details versus is it ethical to share it
knowing technology might be biased
and racist and other concerning things
fantastic thanks donna
so we have another question here that
is asking when an image cannot be
analyzed
because it's a bad image the algorithm
should also suggest what the user might
need to do to improve it like maybe move
a little to the right or
something like that and the question is
is that part of the algorithm challenge
yes we have a number of challenges
because it turns out uh so in the case
of image capturing
we have a challenge that will be coming
out
it will the paper should be publicly
available over the next week
it will be posted to archive and it will
be published as part of
the set of papers for cbpr 2020
about assessing the image quality
one side of that is if someone is trying
to post a picture
to social media that person might want
to make sure it looks high quality
and want some sort of feedback from the
algorithm of you know did i
appropriately center the person in the
image
or the scene or something else to that
effect
and so we are putting out a challenge on
that front
that supports um that has algorithms
that can tell
a user whether the images are blurry
if they're too bright they're too dark
if the view is rotated and so give some
sort of fine-grained information
to help that photographer make certain
adjustments
we also are releasing with that work
a data set that supports design of
algorithms
that lets a person learn
whether or not that image is a
sufficient
quality to be captioned so sometimes
an image is just taken and it's just all
black it's all white it's just way too
blurry
and a sighted viewer can't even make out
what is the content of midnight
and in that case it's nice to fail fast
to have an algorithm say hey
look this image isn't bright quality
let's try to take another one again
um that's on the image captioning side
we also have in our challenge on the
visual question answering side
the task of being able to design
algorithms
that will immediately tell a user
whether or not
the question that that person asked
about the image is answerable
a a question about an image may be
unanswerable
because the image is low quality as
described before
but it can also be the case because the
content of interest is missing
from the image as an example a lot of
questions asked
looking at some food what is the expert
expiration date
of that food and often it can be the
case when someone takes an image
that that expiration date is not even
visible in the scene
in that case you would want the user to
try to take the picture again
and i guess i'll just close on that
section saying please visit our website
at fizzwiz.org
and you can find all these data sets
with challenges for doing assistive
photography on that website
awesome thanks donna so there's a
question here that all
i can take when there's a few different
questions here that are around to
um the geographic or
sort of cultural specificity of
these kinds of systems and the questions
really are like one of the questions is
does the data set have geographic
tagging
in it and i think the answer to this
data set is no
because of the privacy issues associated
with it but it is certainly the case
that you could imagine
that having some kind of information
about
where the images are taken can be very
helpful
in parsing and understanding what might
be going on there
so for instance an image images that are
taken
in india or egypt are likely to be very
different kinds of images
than are going to be taken in south
africa or taken in paris
and these kinds of things can be useful
in improving
the recognition or in the way in which
we present
captioning associated with it because
you're going to have different kinds of
of information there but for this data
set
we needed to take all that out because
of the privacy issues associated
with this kind of geo tagging is that
right donna
yes that does sound great great thank
you
so i am looking at the questions and i
see
another question here saying it's
talking more on the technical side and
it's talking about that there's
classification data sets
like imagenet which are very rich as far
as visual information and details
and the question is can we make use of
these classification data sets
to help detection and captioning
problems
so we were interested in the exact same
question when we put out this captioning
data set
and so we actually did a thorough
analysis
to figure out what is the overlap
between
the objects that are being described by
users shown images taken by people's
blind
and the objects that are found in the
classification data sets such as
internet
as well as a number of other popular
computer vision data sets
and so at you know over as an overview
all that data set is now available all
that analysis
is now available on archive in ap her
that will be on business.org
but in a nutshell we find there's about
fifty percent overlap
um sorry let me step back
there's much less overlap there's a very
small overlap in terms of
the kinds of objects that are described
in
the images that are taken by people's
blind
versus the kinds of objects that are
found
in those classification datasets and so
what that tells us
is that even if you have an amazing
architecture
that you train on today's existing data
set
they're going to probably not do well on
these novel
images taken by people who are blind
because there's a big
mismatch in the kind of content
and so um there is some ability to
leverage existing
data sets but there's it will only help
for very narrow
sliver of the interest that people who
are that we see
within the images we're working with
so donna there's two questions here
about these this is just to extend this
a little bit about the data sets
and then the question is um
are there is there a capability to add
more images
into the data set either because you're
just trying to expand it
or to provide um
things that are more general for
particular regions you know
the one of the observations here is that
many of these things were taken in the
usa
and so any of the algorithms that are
developed are likely to be
more appropriate for
the u.s or european contacts as opposed
to say
africa or asia or et cetera how
are there is there plans or is there a
way to expand these data sets more
to create more images
yes um excellent question i was
thrilled to see this past year that a
new paper came out
introducing a new data set that was
collected using
pictures taken by people who are blind
in
south korea so that is available
in live today um and
i'll have to i'm looking at google
scholar to see if i could quickly find
it but
going through how was that collected how
do we start to think about how do we
enlarge this data set
that's a key challenge that this team
was able to address
and what they did is they went ahead and
built an
application using the mobile phone um
that supports a user
to record a spoken question take a
picture and have those submitted
and what the team that put the status
together did
is they beforehand paid people
who are blind and i believe low vision
as well
to use this app in their daily lives and
to submit the data
and those people signed a waiver and
agreed to be part of
providing a solution to help them meet
their daily needs
so these people very willingly and
knowingly understood that they were
going to share their data to try to help
the advancement
of technology and while it's a bit
different
from what happened from viswiz because
in a business case
people were immediately getting answers
to their questions from online crowd
workers
it's it still supports this generation
of a larger scale data set and it
absolutely
addresses the need for us to go beyond
a u.s centric environment and really
think about what are the needs from
people all across the world
so that is one promising direction and
i guess you know i think we need to
continue to think creatively
on the front of how do we continue to
expand the sizes of these data sets
so there's a question here about
designing neural networks here which
which work for the problem and the
question is just is it trial and error
by just adding extra layers or tuning
hyper parameters randomly or
you know is there a a best practice
for trying to start to develop these
kinds of
of algorithms and maybe the right answer
here is just to start pointing people to
some of the
the um papers where this is being
effective i guess yeah so
you know there's certainly in the
machine learning way of thinking
a lot of trial and error i would say
we are going to great lengths to try to
provide metadata so we can start to
decipher what is hard versus easy for
algorithms
and so i'll give you an example one
part of our metadata is flagging for
each image
whether or not text is present in an
image right so today's
image captioning algorithms are trained
on images that
don't typically have text in them okay
so we wouldn't expect for today's image
captioning algorithms to do well in that
environment
and intuitively we might go into this
problem thinking
absolutely we need to put in some sort
of
optical character recognition mechanism
into the algorithm design
and so to support this analysis to see
was our hypothesis
correct we both analyze the algorithms
overall
overall as well as looking at how do
algorithms perform on those images that
don't have text
and how do algorithms perform on those
images that do have
text and we found a very surprising
finding
which is that algorithms actually do
better on
images that have text so
that evoked for us a natural question of
why would that be
these tools there's no reason to believe
they can read
what's going on in the images and what
we believe is going on
is that algorithms for caching images
are doing well
because they typically can follow an
overall trend of
a person is holding a bottle that says
something
okay so maybe they can get most of the
caption right
without getting the details of what's
the text within it maybe you know
typically people are
holding something when they are trying
to have text read
from an object okay so that was a
surprising
finding but it also tells us
kind of a future direction which is you
can get
far with existing image captioning
algorithms
that doesn't necessarily mean you're
providing the information that's of
interest to this population
and so yes we need to add in text
analysis capabilities
um and we have done similar analysis
across other variables so looking at
with metadata about
the quality of images as well as the
type of
quality flaws that are present as well
as
um yeah we just have a number of
various metadata and i would encourage
people to stay tuned onto
our viswos.org because that is a growing
list of metadata that we are providing
and all that
is searchable i'd like to add through
our
vizwiz dataset browser you can see the
various kind of metadata that's
available
to help kind of start to tease out what
makes
these problems hard for modern
architectures and what kinds of modules
we might need to add
cool so there's a question that is is
kind of useful here which
which i think is is especially
interesting for this kind of
work because most of the analysis that
we're doing
is based on crowds and providing a lot
of the
details the ground truth on this there's
a
interesting question around biases
associated with these crowds can you
talked about that a little bit donna
yes that is a great question so
a lot of these data sets are built on
relying
on you know taking an image and asking
some online worker
from for example amazon mechanical circ
to describe that image
or given the image with the question
provide an answer
the challenge is that people who are
working on these platforms
are not necessarily familiar with what
are the interests
of people who are taking the pictures so
i'd like to provide an example to paint
this picture so
um an image we had
we had almost total agreement from five
different people
from this crowdsourcing platform in
describing this image
and what each of them said was something
along the lines of
a person is wearing a green shirt with
white text
that says the following so
people all more or less agreed on what
should be the description of this image
however if you look at the question that
the person wanted answered
about the image the question was
is this shirt dirty or clean okay
there are many more examples like that
including pictures
of toilets bathtubs
and descriptions usually describe what's
the you know it's a toilet or it's a
bathtub
and or you know this isn't a very
interesting image for captioning
but what the person wants to know again
in those cases is
is this clean they just probably tried
to clean these
um you know the their bathroom or their
house and they want to know
did i do a good job or their remnants
and so that's just one layer of example
but more generally there can be a
mismatch
and understanding from these crowd
workers in terms of
what is it that people who are blind
actually want described in these images
and so i'd like to add to that that we
are currently undergoing user studies
to interview people who are blind and we
have our first publication out
it will be discussed at it's part of the
kai 2020
literature but it's actually directly
going to
a select group of people with visual
impairments and asking them
what do you want described and so we are
trying to get some traction
so we can provide templated
instructions to crowd workers going
forward to really help
crowd workers figure out how to provide
the information that is wanted
and so hopefully in the next couple
years a new data set will be coming out
in in that way
awesome all right well it looks like we
have time for maybe
one more question and i'm going to
choose a question here that
is goes back to the beginning of the
webinar when we talked about inclusive
design
and fundamentally it's asking how do
our findings generalize but beyond just
supporting people who are blind in low
vision
so i'm going to take a first swing at
this and then i'm going to i think donna
has some really great ideas on this as
well
and i would say that from my perspective
one of the things about this work
is that it's fundamentally about
taking imperfect images or images that
are taken in particular context
or particular reasons why people are
taking these images
and then responding to that rather than
overall kind of perfect images that
say an ms cocoa etc might be taken and
the reason why that's really important
for generalized use
is that most people are not taking
perfect photographs whenever they want
to
understand what's going on in the world
and whether that
is because you're blind or because your
car
is trying to understand objects in the
road or
because any kind of computer vision
system is likely going to have
particular context or
ju reasons why they're there and so that
data
that is generalized that is generated
for those
contacts is going to be really
particular and so the techniques that we
learn to use
for people that are blind and low vision
can apply
much more broadly across this big
spectrum of other kinds of computer
vision uses
and indeed i think many other kinds of
artificial intelligence tasks
no donna what do you think yes i
100 agree and just to extend that even
further
our data sets are the first data sets
that allow us to do
some sort of fine-grained analysis to
understand
how our algorithms doing when working on
a low quality image
versus a high quality image because we
provide metadata where you can separate
out the low quality of my quality and
then analyze algorithms
similarly as i mentioned before it
allows for us to look at when images
have text versus not
and so our data set offers the ability
to explore
these challenges that are really
abounding around the world
and some specific examples i can think
of
that are very relatable to what we have
learned from this data set
is this new trend of wearable lifelong
devices
certainly these issues are prevalent for
autonomous vehicles
and robots and i would also talk about
you know we we discussed the issue of
privacy and with coronavirus
a lot of us are now sitting behind our
computers doing meetings that
possibly are being recorded and have
lots of private information that are now
being captured
you know ranging from
pictures of your face to things in your
house that you may not want to be
publicly shared and so
while this data set was collected from
one population i very much believe
we will find that what we are learning
from the data set will
have lots of potentially positive
impacts on society at large
awesome all right i think
that with that we are going to call this
uh
good i want to thank you all very much
for attending today we really do
appreciate your
your participation and your interest in
the domain
if you're interested in learning more i
want to remind you that we have some
great resources in the resource list to
the right of your screen
this list includes links to the viswas
data set the workshop coming up in june
and a number of other goodies including
our websites where there are lots of
publications associated with that
we're really looking forward to seeing
how you build on this research
and evolve how computer vision can be
used for people who are blind
we are really passionate about this area
as you can probably tell
and we would love to have more great
minds from all over the world attacking
it
i hope you have a great day and good
luck
you